>> Hello, I wanted to talk seriously and honestly for a moment about
my thoughts on what's been going on for the past couple months, and hopefully
You can get a better understanding
Of my perspective.
I think it's time to end the "Subscribe To PewDiePie" movement or meme.
It's something that started off as a way to keep me as the number one, most subscribed channel on YouTube,
and
seeing so many people come to my support, other creators as well,
has been incredibly humbling to me.
It's really really meant a lot.
It's something I never thought I would experience
And it's something I thought would last almost for maybe just a couple of days, or maybe a week. But here we are.
It's been six to seven months now and it's been a crazy journey. At first it started off with
people doing really positive and fun things to get attention through "Subscribe To PewDiePie"
But something I learned and I think hopefully it's something people can understand is when you have 90 million people
riled up about something, you're bound to get a few degenerates, and it started off with someone
spray-painting "Sub To Pewdiepie" on a World War II memorial and just so disgusting, so disappointing, to have my name and community
dragged into that, I
addressed it on Twitter, I disavowed it. We saw that it got removed, and- and donated to the park.
Hoped that that was gonna be it. I didn't want
hateful acts to overpower all these amazing things that people were doing. All these cool and positive things.
But then something happened that I don't think anyone would have predicted.
The Christchurch shooter said "Subscribe To PewDiePie" Out of the respect for the families and victims
involved, I chose not to address it any further than on Twitter, where I disavowed the actions taken that day and I
gave my sincerest condolences to everyone affected. To have my name
associated to- with something
so unspeakably vile has affected me in more ways than I let shown, I just didn't want to address it right away.
And I didn't want to give the terrorist any more attention.
I didn't want to make it about me
because I don't think it has anything to do with me. To put it plainly
I didn't want hate to win, but it's clear to me
now the "Subscribe To PewDiePie" movement should have ended then. Lastly my feelings around the
"Subscribe to PewDiePie" thing would not be complete without mentioning T-Series
Uhh, I made two diss tracks that were made in fun, ironic jests
They were not meant to be taken seriously, and
now High Court in India demands that they're gonna be blocked, and removed
This was all made to be fun, but it's clearly not fun anymore. It's clearly gone too far and out of respect for that
I'm gonna keep the videos blocked. On a similar note, some people in some media has made this
"Sub To PewDiePie" thing about race or about politics or nationality,
and
I don't agree with that at all
and I want that to stop.
This negative rhetoric is something I don't agree with at all and I want that to stop and to make it perfectly clear:
No, I'm not racist. I don't support any form of racist comments or hate towards anyone.
Finally,
I don't want hitting a hundred million subscribers to be about beating another channel.
I think what we've accomplished is so much more than that, and I just want to say I feel
incredibly lucky to have such an amazing group of people supporting me
I think I can say that because I know them better than anyone. I unironically,
I'm so proud of this community and this movement started out of love and support, so let's end it with that.
I hope that you understand my perspective, and I ask you kindly to accept it. Thank you for listening.
That's all, bye.